Speaker 1: Why don't we check in here with
Brian from Phenix? Brian, you're on the air.
Hey, David, can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Speaker 5: I was listening to one of your
recent episodes regarding the Kyle Rittenhouse
shooting. You were talking about how it's
representative of all of the the problems with
gun culture. And you know, the the fact that
Kyle Rittenhouse felt justified in going there at
all is sort of indicative of all of those issues.
Speaker 1: Yes, parenting, gun
culture, vigilantism, etc. Would you?
Speaker 5: You know, I actually I agree with
a lot of that. Would you also say that there
is a similar issue with the way that many of the
protesters felt justified in being there around,
like the particulars around the Jacob Blake
shooting? In terms of, you know, is there any
onus on the media that portrayed the shooting in
the way that it did, given you know what we know
about it now that you know the what was occurring
before the police got there, the kids in the car,
the knife in the seat, all of those things, those
Speaker 1: are there's kind of two questions
there, and I think it's important to be really
careful. The protesters, to the extent that people
were protesting, I'm not talking about looting,
arson or anything like that. That's that's against
the law and I'm against it. But the protesting
and marching and holding signs and saying things
constitutionally protected paramount element
of the United States of America, right? That's
that is beyond reproach as long as
you're doing it in a nonviolent way.
The second part is were they ginned up into
a frothy state because of media coverage,
which could have been different? That is totally
plausible. I don't remember the coverage now,
and I'm I, you know, I wouldn't need to
study it more. It's completely plausible
that media could bear a responsibility for
raising tensions. I'm not saying they did.
I'm just saying it's theoretically possible. But
that's a different issue from the. I don't think
we can say that there's a problem with a culture
where people feel like it's OK to go and protest,
that it is OK to go and protest, and
we want to be really clear about that.
Definitely. Yeah. All right, Brian, thank you
so much for the call. That's going to do it for
calls today. I do plan and hope to take more
calls again soon, and I will speak to you then